こちらカール社長です今日は僕が昔からずっと欲しかったものをちょっと変わってき
ますね
山から近くであると思わなかったですがこちら携帯型心理診断鎮圧執行システム
ドミネーターでございますサイコパスっていうアニメがあるんですけどもそのアニュ
ねぇで使われていた中のことでございますこ1曲の間しかちっこ
あんだけが携帯使用可能な大型拳銃状の装置
対象に症状を向けることでサイコばそういう人に最優先でシビラ知って武具解析する
ことで犯罪係数を計測する機能をもつ対象の犯罪ですよしーすど的思考と選択する形状
機能が変化する15逃げ本体に触れているもので引っ越しこうしてほしいと猛爆矯正
以上経ちや差し金使用車消防船だったとにかけて以外に特別旭町
試合最後かさを見せない人にはわけわかんないと思うんですけどもうあかんだと言い
ましょう人間の心理造替性格をね低速して数値化できるようになった未来の話なんで
ちょっとね心の状態とか数値化で表すことができてその測定した数値のことを最後パス
と
よって数値が高ければ高いほどその犯罪をするを性があると潜在判決
実際に犯罪はしないんですけども犯罪するかもしれないということで数値が高い人に
この銃を向けるとまぁその数値によって変わるんですけどもパラナイター
痺れさせたり殺しちゃったりで対象に銃を向けて数値が高ければ高いほどその意欲が
増すと言うという勢がこちらの後メーターになっております
最後パス本当に面白い子ですね僕はですねそのねヒロインだねボヤ金ちゃんが大好きな
んですよなかわいいって話じゃないんですけどねずっと欲しかったしなんか2万円
くらい吸っ無駄にたかったんですけどこちらのドミネーターちょっと開けて使って
みようと思います
怖いね全てがその数値で決められるって社会なんてどんなによくて再度があっても数値
が最後ばせ
雪が高ければもう問答無用でこのサービスっていう世界です数値化された社会疑問没
アニメなんですけどもう大かっこいい
おおーー
これかこちらの富データーです電池が入ったらしいからまだ使い風にスタンドをつい
てる
このああこれがをし悲しかったよねこれを頭とするで功執行 ino ん
id 角に完了しましたあなたは肇社長ですね
水の使用を許可します
って感じではずなんですけど等身大などこの大きならしいして実践中も管財係数測定
スイッチボード切り替え電子でんしぇいぷ汁
ファー
振っこれぞ当局ここですなーここで電池入れるよと思います ok これで短っ簡単
よう3つ
うわぁ
起動しましたねこんな感じですもうちょっとねこういう音ちょっと led 啓発やに
完全ちちょっと暗くしようか
うっ
あーよかったってきてユーザらしいですね相次ぐちょっと比べしてみました
led が綺麗に着てるんだよ早速ちょっと触ってみましょう
ぶりっ子
俺が出航対処
ほっを
第三国は際サイコパス数値が110執行対象なしですこのボタンを押すとなんか安い
です
僕のその犯罪ケースでが分かるらしいです
うん
260完全に半数少女あいているこちらのドミネーターなんですけどもう
先ほども言ったように犯罪ケースサイコパスの集中によってその
打つか打たないかっていうねロックが自動的に掛かってパワー倒すたりしますさんずい
係数が100以上の場合セーフティ会場で見てるの管財係数が99以下の場合はドン
執行最初ではない
でトリガーをロッテされるというか言ってる人いますそれ混ぜ粉望みネーター使ってと
他の音ユーチューバーをねちょっと犯罪者かどうかっていうのでちょっと犯罪係数で
これ測ってみてそのユーチューバーの犯罪係数が99以下だと鳥がロックして待つのみ
がますだからそのユーチューバーの犯罪兄弟が100以上の場合僕が殺しますでは行き
ました
たいときで順番ちょっと youtube の犯罪係数を確かめていこうと思います
まずはヒカキンさんです
me
おおーー
日限りなハンド意見書32です会はやはりいいとですね良かったり吸ったり弁っていう
予想
好きって
ee
平均30ですね犯罪係数彼は全く犯罪係数が0なので彼が完全に猛反対するおそれが
ないということが分かりましたね
兄さんはやっぱり人ですね良かったです
uh
なんてことをじゃあさっそく確かめてみようと思います
me
hauhau
4 f
ええええ
b 4位
しています